Caroline Aghajanian: On this
episode of "Travel Dares":
I'm taking Nico to La Grande Fistoire,
where were gonna cross a
200-foot suspension bridge.
Whoo! Oh, my God!
No, no!
Nico Reyes: And I'm taking Caroline to
Savonnerie Marseillaise de la Licorne,
where we're gonna learn how soap is made.
Caroline: Come join us on our adventures
on this episode of "Travel Dares."
This is "Travel Dares,"
the show where we do daring
activities all over Europe,
empowered by my Marriott
Bonvoy Boundless card.
In this episode, Nico and I
are in the south of France.
Nico, how are you doing?
Nico: I am so psyched! I'm
really excited to be here.
I've always wanted to come
to the south of France,
and I can't wait to get started.
Caroline: Yes! So, here
is your first clue.
Nico: Hand it over!
OK.
I have no idea what that could mean.
Caroline: You're just
gonna have to find out.
Nico: It's definitely gonna
be something, like, active.
Either, like, maybe climbing, running.
Best foot forward? That's
where my mind goes.
Caroline: A via ferrata
is a climbing route
using steel cables that
hikers secure themselves to.
They're super popular
among European hikers,
and this one happens to have
a super scary bridge right in the middle.
Nico, I'm so excited for you!
Nico: I know!
I wanna rip this blindfold off.
Caroline: OK, we're almost
there, just a few more steps.
Nico: OK.
Caroline: Take your blindfold off,
because we are walking across that bridge!
Nico: No, we're not!
Caroline: Yes, we are!
Nico: Oh, my God!
That is so high!
Caroline: OK, we're hiking up now.
We have about a 15-minute hike
until we actually get to the bridge.
Nico: I was half right about my clue.
'Cause we are hiking it up.
Caroline: We are. We're
doing something active.
Nico: I always wanted to
be a little more athletic.
And we're building so much muscle!
Caroline: Oh, we're
getting really steep here.
I'm climbing.
There's no more trail, so
we're just going on rocks now.
I'm scared.
Nico: All right, so, we're about
to go on the bridge! Finally. We made it!
Caroline: It's taken...this
was not 15 minutes,
let me tell you that.
Oh, boy!
Oh, my God!
Nico: I will never, oh, my God!
Caroline: Oh, God!
Nico: You got this, Caroline.
Caroline: My arms are shaking.
Please, please, can we go faster?
Nico, are you OK?
Nico: I'm good.
OK, I'm OK.
I'm nervous.
Caroline: Oh, my God,
oh, my God, oh, my God.
I'm on the bridge.
Nico: Oh, God!
OK, Caroline.
Caroline: Hi.
Nico: I'm sorry.
Caroline: It's OK. Just come on.
Nico: Hello, hello,
hello, hello, hello. OK.
Caroline: Oh, my God!
OK, we're on the bridge.
[Nico exhales]
Chandra: On the right side.
Caroline: How are you doing, Nico?
Nico: I'm good, this is incredible!
Caroline: Oh my God!
Nico: The view. It's so...
Caroline: I am terrified,
but I've never felt more
confident in my life!
Nico: The air up here is incredible!
Whoa, it does make me a little bit
nervous when the wind blows!
[Caroline screams]
Nico: Oh, my God!
Caroline: The wind, the wind!
Nico: Oh, no, no, no, no!
Caroline: Nico, are you OK?
Nico: Caroline, this wind is really bad.
Caroline: Oh, my God!
[Caroline breathes heavily]
You're OK!
Nico, you got this! Let's sing a song.
La, la, la, la.
Nico: I feel like, for
something that scared
me so much just to get to,
I'm smiling a whole lot.
'Cause this is, like, once in a lifetime.
I'm never gonna have this view again.
I'm never gonna be this
on top of the world again.
"Travel Dares"!
Both: "Travel Dares"! "Travel Dares"!
Nico: No one can ever say
anything to me ever again.
I am the bravest woman alive,
and I don't care what you say!
Caroline: We made it!
Nico: Now that we did it,
Caroline, I feel really good.
Caroline: I do feel good.
Nico: We just did that!
Caroline: We did that!
Nico: We did that!
Whoo!
Chandra: Congratulations!
Nico: Oh, God, that was intense.
Caroline: Rocks! Oh, my God, rocks!
Nico: The rocks are
comforting to Caroline.
Caroline: You guys, we
made it! Nico, we made it!
[cheering]
Nico: I'm freaking proud of us!
Caroline: I am so proud!
That was the wildest thing I've ever done!
All right, Nico, now let's
get off this mountain.
Nico: I cannot believe we survived that.
Caroline: I know, Nico, that was probably
one of the hardest dares we've done.
But you absolutely killed it.
I'm so proud of you!
Nico: Thank you!
I hope I can say the same about
you when it comes to my dare.
Caroline: OK, well let's
see what your clue is.
OK!
Nico: What are you thinking?
Caroline: A spa day, most likely.
Nico: Let's hope.
Caroline: OK!
[laughing]
Caroline: The first thing that...
oh, wait.
Wait a minute.
I feel like we're making soap.
I feel like that's what we're gonna do.
We're gonna make soap.
Something in the beauty world.
Um, I don't know, and we're also
gonna integrate lavender in this somehow.
That's what I think.
Nico: Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
[Caroline cheers]
Caroline: It smells good!
Nico: Stand right there
and stick your hand out.
Caroline: Stick my hand.
Nico: What do you think that is?
Caroline: It's soap!
Nico: Take off your blindfold.
We're making soap today!
Caroline: We're making soap?!
Oh, my God!
Nico: Look at this place!
Caroline: Oh, my God,
this is like soap heaven!
Caroline and Nico: Bonjour Jerome!
Jerome Monge: Bonjour, nice to meet you.
Caroline: Thank you for having us!
What are we doing today?
Jerome: We are making lavender soap today.
Caroline: Lavender.
Nico: I love lavender.
The smell of lavender soap is so good.
Caroline: Yes!
Jerome: It is in this machine
where there is initial mix
between oil and soda. Soda
is a sodium hydroxide.
Because all the soap are made with
this soap mix: fat and soda.
And, here, there is the
little pieces of soap.
We are going to put in this machine.
Caroline: Whoo!
[Nico laughs]
Soap pebbles!
Nico: Is our soap coming out?
Caroline: I see it, I see it!
Nico: Oh, there it goes!
Caroline: This is so mesmerizing.
Nico: We make some pretty beautiful soap.
Caroline: I know, this is fantastic.
Jerome: And after, when we
have this paper of soap,
we are going to put it in this mixer.
And after, we are going to prepare, right,
the perfume and the color
to put in this machine.
Nico: Caroline, I'm gonna
press the green button again,
and you start pouring.
Caroline: You got it.
Nico: Oh!
The purple's coming!
Caroline: Wow!
Nico: Look at that!
This feels like our soap
is finally coming to life!
Caroline: I know, our
little baby's being born!
Nico: Our lavender soap!
Caroline: That's a more essential oil.
Nico: Oh, the smell's hitting me again.
Jerome: And this machine can transform
the flakes of soap in tagliatelle of soap.
Nico: Pasta!
Jerome: You make pasta of soap.
It's the same machine to make pasta.
It's good.
Caroline and Nico: Oh!
Nico: Oh, my God!
Caroline: Oh, my God!
Nico: That does look like pasta.
Caroline: It is pasta!
Jerome: Next, you are going to take
this tagliatelle of
soap to compact the soap
to give the final shape to soap.
Nico: Ready, Caroline?
Caroline: Ready!
Nico: Let's see our soap.
Both: It's coming out!
Caroline: Here it comes!
It's like a long snake.
Jerome: Cut and use our tang.
And you....
Nico: You made a bar of soap!
Caroline: I made a bar of soap!
Jerome: That's good.
Caroline: One, two!
Oh.
Jerome: Stronger, be very strong.
[Nico laughs]
Or you can stamp two timers,
so if the first one go....
Caroline: Oh, two times,
like pound it two times.
Nico: That may be better.
Caroline: One here, one here maybe?
Jerome: Yes.
Caroline: OK, I'ma do that.
Boom! Boom!
Nico: That one's good!
That one is really good!
Jerome: And after, you push.
Caroline and Nico: Oh!
Nico: It's gonna be loud, I'm scared.
It's, like, screeching.
Take the excess off.
Is it coming out on its own?
Ew!
That was weird.
That was so weird!
Caroline: Oh, my God, Nico,
these are gonna make such great gifts!
And we get to tell everybody
we helped make them!
Little soapmakers.
We've been to Northern France,
and now we're in the south of France,
and they're both so different.
Like, they both have their
own unique charm to it.
Nico: Yeah, I agree.
I definitely loved experiencing
the culture around here.
And the croissants.
Caroline: Nico, are you
ready for your rating?
Nico: Yes!
Caroline: OK, so, I have
to say, this is probably
one of the hardest dares
we've ever done on this show.
We had to climb up that
challenging mountain,
and then we scaled down to
get to the super-scary bridge.
And I'm so impressed of how
well you handled yourself.
So I'm giving you five out of five stars.
Nico: Yes!
Caroline: I'd give a 10
if I could, Nico!
Nico: Oh, my gosh!
Caroline: It was so good!
Nico: Five on my first
dare ever. I'm so psyched!
Caroline: You deserve it.
Nico: Thank you,
thank you, thank you, thank you!
Caroline.
Caroline: Yes.
Nico: I was expecting
you to love soapmaking,
just because you're a huge
fan of everything beauty.
You were working that
soap-slicing machine like a champ!
No fear that your fingers
could be chopped off
at any moment.
And for that, I will give you
one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
Caroline: Yes!
Five lavender stars!
Nico: You did a really, really good job.
Caroline: Thank you so much.
They still smell so good!
Thank you so much.
Nico, this was so much fun.
I can't wait to go all
over Europe with you!
Nico: Cheers!
Caroline: Cheers!